this is kind of an exciting time of year
for me my blood gets pumping a little
bit because it's break up and break up
to me is like New Year's to most people
so I start my calendar year the day the
river breaks up and looking at the river
breakup is going to happen real quick
here so I got all my food dry good food
type supply is here and next step I got
to do is I got to get going on getting
some boats together create an arc for me
and the dogs in case we flood I'm always
nervous after the flood in 2009 you
never know what this river is going to
do it can be your best friend or it can
kick your ass in 2009
Andy Passage experienced one of the most
devastating breakups of the Yukon River
in recorded history the resulting flood
cost him valuable equipment and
machinery and took the life of a member
of his dog team having spent years
rebuilding his livelihood it's critical
for Andy to take every precaution
against the impending breakup in order
to protect his home and the lives of
himself and his sled dogs
my next job is I got to get my army
boats turned over get them Stern to
stern and then connect them up to each
other and that'll make about a 40-foot
long barge that's the Ark it's really
important to to create a safety net at
break up here so I'm gonna have to get
some boats put together get it set up
for dogs have some food in there some
water in there because you never know
out here at break-up time this could be
what we call a slush out where the river
just breaks up and goes out nice and
easy
or it could be an ass-kicker and if it's
an ass-kicker I might be in a boat for
24 hours waiting for the water to go
back down although it creates a lot of
extra work for me
it's a whole lot more work if I don't do
this prep in 2009 the water level came
up from River level to flooding this
property in probably less than 15
minutes 20 feet of water rise in 15
minutes you don't have a whole lot of
time to react right now my mind is all
wrapped around priorities take care of
the material things around here that
will get ruined in a flood and then the
second top priority is the safety for me
and the dogs in the boat come on come on
coop yeah come on bring us come on brick
come on brick yeah good job in the boat
good job in the boat so what will happen
is I can clip them in and they're secure
where Jack
there you go buddy exciting go through
and just secure dogs in like this and
then everybody's under control okay the
floods over plugs over go play okay
everybody out of the boat let's go what
let's go on to the next job